but i'm gonna tell you the best part
about this movie the absolute best part
about thor love and thunder
is christian bale
man this dude is a good actor okay like
they did
his role
like they opened the movie up with
christian bales like so you know they do
this a lot in movies okay
you know there's no need for spoiler
you're gonna like we need to know why
the hero is needed and this is like a
thing they do in a lot of movies they
open up with like the big bad guys
robbing a bank or like you know you know
what i mean like you like we like like
in batman
and batman um uh a dark dark night you
know when we first met the joker the
movie opens up
with the joker's crew robbing the bank
so you can get it so you need to know
ooh
this dude this is you know so they
really set up it's a great like i would
have liked to have seen just that movie
about him
what